(4D Shapes Falling)
This is a video about
life in other dimensions.
Flat lifeforms in 2D landscapes, psychedelic
entities with higher spatial geometry, even
beings that can ignore time.
While our 3D brains can typically only perceive
a limited number of dimensions, with the help
of computer simulations and a bit of sci-fi
creativity, we can conceptualize some truly
mind-blowing hypothetical realities.
So, say goodbye to the 3D world you know,
and prepare for life in lower and higher dimensions…
We’ll start by voyaging down a dimensional
layer, to a universe of 2D Life.
The beings of this universe can only move
on two axes, with no conception of depth.
If we were to stick our faces through the
flat plane of their world, the visual might
be frightening, as the two-dimensional lifeforms
would only be able to perceive infinitely
thin slices of our three-dimensional bodies
at a time, a bit like the images of an MRI
machine.
To those beings, we would be shape-shifters
whose bodies appear from nowhere and disappear
with no explanation.
But could life really function in 2D?
Sure, here’s some now.
This is a simulation running in ALIEN, an
artificial life program that lets you build
two-dimensional ecosystems.
These virtual cells might not be life as we
typically define it, but they do self-replicate
and adapt to environmental changes.
There’s lots of impressive 2D life simulators
out there, but for 2D life to exist outside
of a computer, it couldn’t be made of the
3D atoms we’re familiar with.
Scientist Timm Hurton successfully simulated
a stable molecule in just two dimensions,
so our hypothetical 2D organism could be made
of these bead-like components.
One of the biggest hurdles for two-dimensional
life would likely be innards.
Nearly all three-dimensional animals are built
around a digestive tract that passes through
their bodies, with a hole on one end for eating,
and a hole on the other end for, uh, expelling.
But if a two-dimensional lifeform had such
a system, it would cut the organism in half,
as this ‘advanced simulation’ shows — with
the bifurcated segments of the lifeform falling
apart.
But there might be a solution.
Certain animals like Sea Anemones just have
the one hole, for all their various hole-related
needs.
Which is… something I’m not going to think
too hard about.
But perhaps our theoretical 2D lifeform could
have a similar system, with a single aperture
leading to a simple digestive tract.
Of course, it’s worth noting that just because
something could exist, doesn’t mean it does.
As far as we’re aware, there is no secret
realm of 2D life: it’s just an interesting
hypothetical.
But what would happen if we went up a level,
to a universe of 4D life?
The innovate game 4D Toys is a way for us
three dimensional lifeforms to start getting
our minds around four-dimensional objects.
At first, these objects don’t seem to make
sense, changing shape as we move them and
even disappearing from view entirely.
What’s happening?
To answer that, let’s return to our metaphor
of a 2D being observing 3D objects passing
through its flat realm.
From our perspective, these 3D objects are
straightforward, but to the 2D lifeform, they
don’t follow familiar rules, appearing and
disappearing for seemingly no reason.
As 3D beings, we can see the objects just
fell into the third dimension outside of the
2D plane, but the 2D entity has no awareness
of this.
And that’s exactly what’s happening to
us in 4D Toys.
We’re three-dimensional beings that can
only see a limited, 3D slice of larger, fourth-dimensional
objects.
Take this ball pit filled with 200 4D hyperspheres.
At first, it doesn’t seem like there’s
that many spheres on screen, but if we move
our third dimensional slice through the fourth
dimension, just like you can move a two-dimensional
slice through the third dimension, we can
see the spheres are all there after all.
This model of the fourth dimension is more
than something the developer made up.
These shapes have long been researched in
geometry, and objects like tesseracts, essentially
4D cubes, are well-documented structures.
Now, some of you might be thinking, ‘wait,
the fourth dimension is time.’
Hold onto that comment, we’re going to get
to it.
For now, there’s lots of cool stuff you
can make in 4D, like this 600-sided die, or
fourth-dimensional abacuses, which really
makes me feel like a baby fumbling around
with a toy.
Ever tried to fit a tesseract into a 4D hole?
It’s not easy.
I’m convinced this is how USBs work — you
can’t plug them in on the first try because
they’re 4-D objects — wake up people.
Trying to think in 4D can be a humbling experience,
and can help you sympathize with 2D life.
For example, let’s imagine a 2D entity is
trying to get this sphere out of this ring.
From our 3D perspective, the solution is obvious,
just pull it forwards.
But to a 2D entity, disconnecting the two
shapes would seem completely impossible, and
our solution would look like magic.
But we’d have similar difficulties with
4D objects.
These two rings seem like they could never
be separated, but they actually have a gap
we can’t perceive along the fourth dimension,
allowing them to come apart.
It drives home the point that to a fourth
dimensional lifeform, we might be like newborns,
utterly perplexed by the most basic of their
shapes.
“Struck by the evil prankster’s dimension
ray, space itself shatters around hawkman’s
ship.”
But shapes are one thing.
What would it be like if a fourth dimensional
being pulled us entirely into their four-dimensional
world?
The answer might be the game Miegakure.
Created by the same developer as 4D Toys,
Miegakure takes place in a world with four
dimensions — though we can only perceive
a 3D slice of it.
But Miegakure allows you to move your 3D slice
along the fourth dimension, revealing new
sides to buildings and landscapes you couldn’t
see before.
It can be quite trippy to look at, but this
ability allows you to solve puzzles in interesting
ways.
Say there’s a wall in front you.
You can move your plane of 3D until you reach
a point in 4D space where the wall isn’t
there, then walk right through.
Now, despite being in development for a while,
the game unfortunately still isn’t available
to play, for the understandable reason that
trying to build a four-dimensional world as
a three dimensional being is quite challenging.
“Great Galaxies, where are we?”
“Location, Dimension 23.”
“DiMenSiOn 23?”
Another promising 4D game is 4D Miner.
Created by youtuber Mashpoe, this game resembles
regular Minecraft at first, until you scroll
with the mouse wheel and realize we’re once
again seeing a 3D slice of a much larger 4D
landscape.
Surviving in this world stretches your mind.
Sometimes you’ll think you’re in an area
without trees, only to realize they’re all
around you, just hidden elsewhere in the fourth
dimension.
Other times, you think you’ve found a small
cave, only to realize it’s huge.
But most challenging of all, is the fact you
aren’t alone in this world.
Those hovering shapes belong to fourth dimensional
predators that see you as an easy meal.
Called hyperspiders, their bodies extend into
the fourth dimension, and are considerably
larger than we can fathom.
Because of their fourth dimensional bodies,
hyperspiders are difficult to spot, and even
harder to hide from.
If you build a house to take shelter in, they’ll
often appear inside as if from nowhere.
This is because as 4D predators, hyperspiders
can move through gaps that us 3D lifeforms
can easily overlook.
“Meanwhile, back on the world in our dimension.”
“What are we going to do?”
“I’m afraid gentlemen, we are at their
mercy.”
There are other ways of simulating four-dimensional
lifeforms.
4D Particle Life is a game that works just
like a 2D life simulator, except, of course,
in 4D.
The artificial life on screen right now might
look like simple particles, but every simulated
cell has a much more complex 4D body.
It’s interesting to think about how games
have gone from 2D, to 3D, to now, with a few
games, 4D.
Although side note: many classic 2D games
aren’t truly two dimensional — as characters
can pass in front of and behind objects, so
their worlds contain at least some depth.
What’s really weird is that when you play
a 4D game, you’re technically looking at
a 3D slice of a 4D world rendered on a 2D
screen.
So now that no one is confused, let’s talk
about time travel.
“Now to switch on my time conveyer!”
You might have heard that time is the 4th
dimension, which raises the possibility of
4D life but, like, with time instead.
Whether or not time is best classified a dimension
like the spatial ones has long been a subject
of debate, but let’s run with the idea.
After all, you do ‘move’ through time.
All of us, right now, are constantly traveling
forward from the temporal position we were
in moments ago, simply by existing.
So, by some definitions, you’re already
a 4D lifeform, with three dimensions of space
and one dimension of time.
“What was that strange field we just passed
through?”
“It must have been some sort of time barrier.
Look, a water dinosaur!”
The difficulty is, of course, that we can
only move through time in a single direction.
We are constantly traveling forwards, and
we cannot go back—or even know where we’ll
end up.
If you could see your fourth-dimensional self
across time, stretching all the way from your
first moments to your very last, it’s interesting
to consider how that would change what it
means to be human.
If, from the very beginning of your story,
you knew every moment that’s to come, would
that even be a life as we understand it?
One of the few sci-fi films to seriously consider
the implications of transcending linear time
is Arrival.
The aliens in the movie, called ‘heptapods,’
seem to experience time in a non-linear fashion,
with every moment in their lives, including
their death, as close to the present as any
other.
We’re not talking about a lifeform that
can alter time (not yet, anyway), but rather
entities that can exist at any point along
a predetermined path.
And as the film progresses, the main human
character begins to perceive time the way
the heptapods do.
It’s an ability that proves both beneficial
and heartbreaking, as all the good and bad
in her life become contemporary instances
in time.
One of the hardest parts of time passing is
that the future holds many unexpected tragedies.
But if you knew every tragic event in your
life before they happened, yet couldn’t
change anything, would that really make things
easier?
Another reflection on the melancholy of non-linear
time is the film Interstellar, particularly
in the scene where the lead character falls
into a higher dimensional space within a wormhole,
where they’re able to see into the past
and future.
The strange realm is called a Tesseract, even
though it’s not a 4D-cube in the traditional,
spatial sense.
But like Arrival, Interstellar’s portrayal
of the fourth dimension is more of a thematic
device than a physics lesson — a meditation
on time’s unchangeable nature.
We all want to know where we’re going, but
if you knew where your ship was headed, but
couldn’t change course, perhaps you’d
be better off keeping your eyes closed.
“You are now in dimension 5, the 5th dimension.
Give me the library of Gorr!”
“It was lost when you pulled me into this
world of yours, buddy.”
But what if you could steer the ship, moving
across timelines the same way a higher dimensional
lifeform could move through space, would that
make you 5D Life?
While you ponder that question, let’s play
some chess.
And by that, I of course mean “5D Chess
with Multiverse Timetravel.”
5D chess plays…
basically the same as regular chess.
With the small exception that if a game just
isn’t going your way, you can send one of
your pieces backwards through time, creating
a new branch reality where things can unfold
differently.
And you can do this as many times as you like,
meaning you have to avoid checkmate across
multiple different parallel realities.
You with me so far?
While playing, you can take pieces out from
fifteen moves ago.
You can send your king through time to another
reality, erasing your king from the original
timeline and making it impossible for you
to lose in that universe.
There’s a strategy called ‘Jurassic Rook,’
where you send a rook or ‘castle’ all
the way back to the beginning of the game,
effectively resetting the timeline to its
original state like you’re in Back to the
Future — it’s crazy, and can leave your
mind completely shattered.
“I just saw a trillion different realities
folding on to each other like thin sheets
of metal forming a single blade.”
“Yeah, yeah, the time knife, we’ve all
seen it.”
But what’s potentially even crazier is imagining
how fifth-dimensional entities would hypothetically
function in an ecosystem.
Say you’re a 5D organism, aware of yourself
across multiple timelines.
If you’re caught by a predator in one reality,
it doesn’t matter.
In another point in another timeline, you’re
still doing fine.
Or, you could go full Jurassic Rook and take
out a past version of that predator when they’re
little, or better yet, take out their great
grandparent so they’re never born.
It’s mind-boggling to think about a whole
speculative ecosystem of 5D species trying
to out-juke each other across multiple timelines,
like they are Skynet from the Terminator.
And to be clear, this vision of the 5th dimension
is beyond speculative and hardly the most
scientific…
but while we’re here, can we push things
even further?
“This little trinket just sent you into
the 6th dimension, superman.
The dimension behind mirrors.”
Branching off into alternate realities from
a single timeline is one thing, but what if
you could explore completely new timelines
with completely new rules?
This multiverse model of reality has become
a popular one in recent years, with more and
more pieces of media exploring stories where
divergent timelines collide.
It’s a concept that doesn’t really line
up with the multi-dimensional theories of
quantum physics, but let’s not get into
all that, this video is already plenty confusing.
The most relevant piece of multiverse media
for our purpose of visualizing higher dimensional
life is probably the film Everything, Everywhere,
All at Once.
It’s a story in which various characters
can perceive and even merge with other versions
of themselves from across alternate timelines.
An interesting byproduct of this is that as
humans with brains only mean to perceive a
single reality at a time, focusing on one
reality often means a version of the characters
in another reality suffers.
Like Arrival and Interstellar, the film’s
dimension-bending sequences are largely a
vehicle for themes and emotional beats.
It’s not just a movie about what would happen
if humans had hot-dogs for fingers.
Well, it is a movie about that — but it’s
also a reflection on meaning in the face of
infinity.
In the context of limitless realities, what
is the worth of a single moment?
It’s a question that feels particularly
relevant to life in the age of the internet.
We can download and experience all these different
dimensional simulations, and it’s great!
But it can also be overwhelming.
In one of the film’s most stunning scenes,
the main character embodies all possible versions
of herself across every conceivable reality
— completely losing her identity to the
void of unlimited stimulation.
Everything, Everywhere, All at Once is the
kind of narrative that can make you appreciate
being here, now — an ordinary lifeform with
a reasonable number of perceivable dimensions.
“My readings indicate we are not in time
and space as we understand it.
Apparently, the natural laws of our universe
don’t operate here.”
In terms of higher temporal dimensions, there’s
no real place to go after you’ve encompassed
every point in time in every possible timeline.
But if we leave time and return to spatial
dimensions, we’ve got room to grow.
You now know what a 4D cube looks like, but
how about a 5D cube — with an extra dimension
of space instead of time.
Or a 10D cube?
Yes, all these points and lines represent
a single 10-dimensional hypercube, flatted
out in a way that we can perceive.
You can really keep adding additional spatial
dimensions until things get exponentially
out of control, with the monstrosity that’s
currently on screen a 16-dimensional hypercube.
Unsurprisingly, there’s not a lot of media
that tries to explore life with these types
of dimensions.
The closest example probably comes from Douglass
Adams’s The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy.
In this series, what we know as mice are revealed
to merely be small protrusions into our dimension
belonging to vast, higher-dimensional beings.
It’s a comedic concept that riffs on the
trope of rats and mazes.
Much like how from our top-down perspective
a two-dimensional maze is easy to solve, mice
in Hitchhiker's Guide find our mazes absurdly
simple — which might hold true for any higher
dimensional being.
“You can hide nothing from me.
My x-ray intelligence.”
We could also head in the other direction
and imagine a one-dimensional game — a concept
the same creator who made 4D Miner has a great
take on.
The game is technically a three-dimensional
interpretation of a one-dimension field of
vision, as a completely 1D-game would just
be an impossibly thin line.
Playing the simulation is kind of like living
in a world made solely of barcodes — although
with practice, you can actually get better
at navigating the strange environment.
Or how about a zero-dimensional game, which…
I guess mathematically wouldn’t be a line
but just a single point — okay we’ve pushed
things too far.
In the end, imagining versions of reality
with a different number of spatial or temporal
dimensions can be challenging.
But there’s so many interesting things you
can experience by widening your perspective.
Some forms of media might make you wish for
extra dimensions, while others will make you
appreciate what you have.
It all depends on your point of view.
“We will not live in a two-dimensional world.
We won’t go in one direction, or zig where
we can zag.
We will walk through walls.
We will not be confined.”
There are plenty of other games and pieces
of media that experiment with dimensions of
space and time in their own way that I didn’t
get the chance to talk about.
If you found this subject thought-provoking,
there are links to all the games and simulations
discussed in this video down below, with more
information on all the incredible people who
are building worlds in higher and lower dimensions.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.